I hope they have like a surprise cash
prize like that would be awesome
today we're shooting is a with an
exclamation point that's part of the
title anyways um it's uh it's just like
a variety game show that's essentially
inspired by the game shows that are from
like age alike in Korea Japan Taiwan
Hong Kong it shows that we kind of grew
up you know with our parents like
watching it like in the background and I
you know you kind of I kind of picked up
on it and I all thought it was really
funny and I thought hey you know we have
a great community of Asian American
youtubers why don't we try and do that
here today we're gonna give that a try
we have a live studio audience and
YouTube's helping us out by giving us
this space and it's gonna be fun
I woke up at 6:00 this morning and got
ready and then I picked Chris up and we
got here at around 8:30 I didn't come to
rehearsal was it rehearsal yesterday
okay I'm on rehearsal
I'm 100% under her so it's like whatever
goes we'll just we'll always go with it
Freddy as well I was pretty excited to
meet Freddy W he and Brandon both said
that they watched away we happened it
was really exciting for me like the
lenez drink on set and I feel like that
just means they want us to kind of
loosen up I think that was in the email
so I think just being free and really
just like everybody's kind of going
balls to the wall today is the thing I'm
gonna be excited
ultimately we just want to be able to
bring on more guests more friends more
people from the asian-american community
and the YouTube community the new media
community we would love to just include
everyone in whatever fun games that
we're doing and yeah just really be an
outlet for these personalities to get
outside of what they're normally known
for it I feel like we should just just
like change up the game and just start
with accents right off with that and
just let people think that we're those
guys I'm actually a pretty goofy person
so I think people will get to see a
little bit more of that compared to my
makeup videos we're just doing tutorials
and so I kind of excited about
I'm one of the hosts me and the other
host is Amy Okuda we're gonna be hosting
we have ten guests who are all like
youtubers or actors within the
asian-american community and we're just
gonna go play like games we're gonna
we're gonna play a game and then
whoever's the lose of that one there's
gonna be like a little punishment that
they have to do nothing nothing too
harmful or whatever it's just all in
good fun I know that it's like they're
not gonna do anything too crazy so like
whatever they end the day what what's
there I've never wanted to pull the plug
on it because life's too short if we you
guys start losing already I feel like we
can own the consequences hella hard when
we do do bad stuff really well I have a
lot of faith in our synergy yeah we do
have some good chemistry Clyde f initely
feel like that we're gonna do I'm pretty
excited about the charades I think I got
some charades skills somewhere in my
body
I just think that in the moment if I'm
like looking a competitor in the eyes I
can't I can't back down you know what I
mean that that's just how it is like we
could talk about it and I can see a rise
where I would not do something but if
the cameras rolling and I'm looking
somebody in the face I'm going for it I
don't tell anybody
ya know and another thing that I
practice is I throw people like every
few hours throughout the day just to
keep my strength up so you might see
some people throwing you might see some
throwing down of people as well yeah I
don't know if we're supposed to like
know this yet but like we're like a team
and that's something that we're excited
about we didn't expect that we're like
oh they're not bouncing yeah we're
totally competing so we didn't even like
wake up to say hi to each other this
morning was just kind of like you know
it's kind of get ready together but but
now we get to never get to be a team so
it's us versus everybody